Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning, supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton podcast.
So today's guest is Professor
Neil Torre.
He's an associate professor at
the Technical University of
Munich TUM and has been a
pioneer in physics based deep
learning.
We had a really interesting
discussion today on first of
all, some of his background,
Very interesting that he
actually won an, an Oscar
working in the visual effects
industry for, for movies after
his postdoc and PhD before he
then turned to academia full
time, which is kind of
incredible actually, and is
interesting because I've noticed
the lessons learned from the
visual effects industry in terms
of photorealistic
representations of, of, of the
world is actually something we,
we then talked right the end of
the, the podcast.
So make sure you listen to the
end about the link between
foundation models and surrogates
to world models.
These world models that are
being created essentially as a
synthetic environment to train
autonomous vehicles and robots.
And we actually talked a lot
about whether there needs to be
more physics in these world
models, which I actually thought
was a very interesting
discussion.
And we only got to it at the
end.
But you know, he he's been one
of these people who was doing
deep learning in the mid twenty
10's and early twenty 20s before
ChatGPT and the sort of big
rise.
And it was interesting to him
talk about how his work was
looked in those times compared
to now and some of the barriers,
you know, and, and skepticism
maybe people had.
He's also been someone who's
really pioneered open source and
pushing the boundaries of
differentiable physics and some
of the codes that him and his
team has developed and now have
moved into both generating data
sets like the Super wing data
set, but also addressing the
challenge of foundation models
also from a sort of PDE point of
view in the latest Tadpole
paper.
So we, we, we kind of go through
some of those topics around
those different strategies of
sort of PDE based methods, you
know, pre training on those
versus doing more of the
traditional, I guess, building
out large data sets.
We talk about the role of
startups and industry and
academia.
Interesting to get his
perspectives on that and how all
three can work together to solve
some of these problems.
And we also talk about the open
source, why he's so pro open
source and how we think that can
help progress the, the, the
field along.
He's, he's actually contributed
together with his team, many
important papers covering not
just on fluids, but also on the,
on the weather side, interesting
like weather bench.
So I, I put a whole link list of
papers in the chat notes that
you can in the show notes that
you can have a look at.
But I, I really enjoyed this
conversation.
He's someone who is very modest
in, in what he's done.
But if you actually read his
papers and look through, you can
see he's being quite influential
in steering these topics and
always seems to be one step
ahead of where most of the field
is AT.
And so if you look at his 2025
and 2026 papers, you'll know
what I mean by that.
So hope you enjoy this episode
with Professor Neil Torry.
Well, yeah, thanks for thanks
for joining today.
I, I've been very keen to speak
to you because as I've been
getting up to speed myself over
the past years on machine
learning and differentiable
side.
Your name is a, a constant, you
know, top of the list in terms
of influential papers, in terms
of doing things what seemed to
be earlier than most others have
done, you know, setting the
scene, which suggests to me that
you have quite a good outlook
and, and, and thought on it.
So, yeah, thanks very much for
for for joining.
And yeah, maybe as a starting
question, you took a diversion.
Well, not diversion, but you
spent some time doing visual
effects after your PhD and
postdoc maybe.
What did you do your PhD?
What was the postdoc?
And then I'm I'm intrigued on on
the movie stuff.
Thanks for the invite.
First of all, Neil.
Yeah, I'd be happy to tell about
this.
My background, right or over my
career, I have switched fields a
couple of times.
My PhD was in a in a
computational numerics
computational physics lab,
basically targeting multi grid
methods and and fluids.
And then I switched to computer
graphics for a while.
I guess that that actually was
one of my driving my motivations
from the start.
I guess I'm a visual person.
I'd like to see how things
evolve.
And I think that's that's still
actually one of the main things
that's fascinate me about
fluids, these swirling motions
and the things that actually do
come out once it's working.
So we also worked on computer
graphics, BASIC for computer
based animation for quite a
while.
My post I get ETH and then
afterwards also did actually
work in industry for a while
because I was curious how things
would actually work out in
industry in a practical
environment.
And partially also because I
couldn't really get a good
faculty position at the time.
So right, not not completely
voluntary in a while in a way,
but right, it was good to see in
the end.
I noticed for me, research is
the more I think the better
field.
But yes, that's that's why we
did my poster basically.
And then I think that if you 10
years ago, we started looking at
machine learning.
So previously we did in this ETH
group what was called
data-driven approaches in
computer graphics, essentially
also trying to work with data
and right, somewhat aligned, but
we didn't have the tools back
then.
So it was, it didn't really
work, to be honest, but we
tried.
And then when Alphago came
along, I thought, oh, this has
to be something that works.
I didn't understand it at the
time, but I thought this,
there's got to be something
there.
And then, yeah, since 10 years,
I think we've been working on,
on basically finding these
techniques to the
reconciliations and food
mechanics specifically.
And I think in a way, it's a
good time at the world.
It's finally starting to work.
But right, it took a while.
So you then joined TUM and
you've been there ever since.
That was your your period.
And so where did you?
What was it like?
I'm trying to put it into the
picture because it's very hard
to the people who were working
on these things before now, you
know, before chat GB Teemo, what
was the field like?
What was the community like?
What was the reception like when
you were bringing up ideas of
sort of data-driven and machine
learning?
Was there a lot of skepticism
and push back?
Yes, actually there was.
So I mean, initially, especially
in the early phases, all these
AIO back then, it was called
deep learning techniques were
focusing on, on learning
descriptors.
I remember our very first papers
and graphics, they, they
basically couldn't synthesize
anything.
You learned some reduced
representation.
They told you about what happens
in high dimensional data, but
right, it, it couldn't really
generate anything.
Also, if you, if you think about
alpha gold, the early success
stories, it was basically 8 by 8
with, with three states.
That's a tiny domain and tiny
state space.
And back then that was
challenging.
So in a way, it really couldn't
do much.
And I, I remember quite well
talking to colleagues and
telling them, look, we're
interested in this deep learning
stuff.
We, we're doing simulations.
And then some of my colleagues
literally laugh me in the face
like, you're doing learning for
Pdes.
What, what could be more
ridiculous?
If you have a PDE and you can
solve it, why, why, why on earth
would you do anything right
learning based And I think so
there was a lot of scepticism
for years.
I always had to defend in the
very first slides of my talks
that this makes sense at all, at
least makes sense to consider
this combination.
And luckily I interestingly, I
think for the for the white
community, I think the picture
really changed with chat GPTI
think in computer science and
and computational fields.
People have been aware earlier,
but since chat ChatGPT it's
really on everybody's plate and
in every view but before.
But you but you were
interestingly was looking
through some of the papers and
you you had slightly earlier on
probably some of the first ones
are sort of like in the AI AA,
the deep learning of like some
random airfoils and so quite a
few in the 20 twenties before
ChatGPT.
So what was it like sort of pre
and post?
Was it was the issue partly the
compute side?
Was it the the architectures?
What?
What was holding back?
Exactly the the architectures
were a fundamental issue.
I think the whole infrastructure
right in the beginning, CNNS
were were a big breakthrough,
yes, for your MLPS.
So CNNS definitely for feel like
data worked quite nicely, but
also right the, the, the shift
from basically computer graphics
to things like aerodynamics.
The a paper you mentioned, we're
a bit motivated by the
observation that it's, it's
really tough to synthesize stuff
in 3D plus time.
You essentially have 40 fields.
Even if you simplify it and and
treat regular geometry as
regular grids, this is really
difficult to do.
It's still challenging these
days actually with, with neural
networks.
So back then it was right bridge
out of the question to do this.
And in graphics, you actually
have extremely good
approximations that aim for the
visual aspect of, of things.
So it, it was extremely tough to
compete with that.
And it was interestingly in the
computer graphics field also, if
you cannot directly apply it on
a scale and, and with a fidelity
that's fit for movies, then your
papers typically get rejected.
It's really, it's computer
graphics makes sense, but it
needs to look good in the end.
So write this 2D proof of
concept simulations.
Even if they were fairly
accurate, you you couldn't do
much.
It had had to be right movie
quality basically.
And and that just was extremely
difficult.
Only also for niche applications
like super resolution.
This was was one that worked
very nicely.
But they can look at repeating
structures and very local fields
for synthesis on on larger
scales, it was basically not
possible.
And that's why we also started
actually doing these proof
concept papers like the the
Iran's predictions by AIA back
then also these were tiny
resolutions, right?
32128 square basically.
So very small domains.
And also I remember back then
actually it's I'm, I'm glad it's
got into a a, but there were
also critical questions even
back then.
Why would you even do this at
all?
This is crude approximations.
Does this make sense?
But yeah, basically we noticed
in in aerodynamics and in
engineering applications,
there's much more demand for
getting things right and really
going forward converged and
solutions that are accurate and
can be evaluated.
And there are many problems
there that that are like really
important basically for for a
variety of industries.
So we basically switched from
from graphics trying to apply
these for engineering
applications.
And where did the, you know, Phi
flow when there's a
differentiable physics, where
did that start to come into the
grid?
Because that seems to be now
quite a hot topic.
But you were publishing in 2020
on these, so where did that
first come from?
I.
Don't even remember, it seemed
like a very obvious thing.
We were working on computational
and numerical methods, the the
networks couldn't really
generate a whole simulation.
So why not start with the
simulator, combining it with the
network and then if you want to
get a gradient through it
actually need differentiability
on on the solver side and right
the the available ones couldn't
do this.
So we just started experimenting
with on solvers since 5:00 flow
became a good testing ground for
very basic methods across
different, different AP is back
then, right there was 10s of
flow and, and Pytorch and JAX
and the whole bandwidth of of
different methods.
So I think it was good for
experimentation and flexibility.
And ultimately we notice here
it's a certain trade off.
Flexibility and generality don't
go too well together.
And so now we're specialising a
bit more.
But five floor was one of these
early testing grounds.
But for us, it really seemed
like in a way obvious, obvious
way to go.
And then later on, we notice,
yeah, there's actually quite
some work to do and also
interesting questions.
How do you get gradients through
long chains of solver
operations, which is still a
topic?
So maybe shifting a little bit
towards the what's going on
right now.
I mean, there's 22 fundamental
questions that I see you've also
been trying to tackle and be
interested to get your thoughts
on it.
And that is around, I guess the
foundation model topic.
The idea of I guess it's
logical, isn't it?
You look at ChatGPT and you see
it as essentially a data-driven
problem that you know, applying
up data, have a decent
architecture and you solve it.
But you well, two questions.
One was on the idea of the
ground truth and can you ever
surpass the ground truth?
And you know, one of your recent
papers looked at can the model
do better than essentially the
quality of the training data?
And the second one is more just
a general question on where you
see the likelihood of foundation
models going.
How, how realistic is it?
But on the first one, maybe you
could explain that paper because
I that really intrigued me
actually, right?
There was actually a great
observation by Phoenix, one of
one of the PhD students from my
group, that he noticed in some
situations.
He also looked at basic
combinations of solvers and
networks and that's the networks
really seem to give extremely
good situations in certain
situations extremely good
results that seem to be even
better than the the training
data we essentially used for
these cases.
And looking into it a bit more,
it's unfortunately not a topic
that I think can be generally
applied and when analysing it in
terms of numerical errors and,
and how these pieces fit
together.
It's basically a combination of
the priors imposed by neural
networks in terms of smoothness,
in terms of right, being able to
over sharp more reproduce and be
trained for producing certain
parts of the solutions that
benefits the the outcome.
So in a way, if you can leverage
or if you understand your
solutions enough to leverage
these particular behaviours of
neural networks, then basically
the outputs can be better than
what you're trained with.
But it's really this interplay
of, of what neural networks do
as essentially also numerical
methods to compute a solution
and what, what's in your data
and what you like to get out.
So it also it raises some
interesting questions on how to
evaluate it because if
especially in the numerical
field, we're trusting the ground
truth, there are also typically
approximation errors in there.
And it it can actually happen
that solutions output by the
network might be even better if
you consider other solves or or
other ways to approximate the
same problems.
But I think it's we also for
this paper thought about it.
It is very difficult to really
do this in a target to way.
So we had some new cases where
it worked for some, some basic
infection fusion and burgers.
Burgers equation was a good
example actually because the the
shock representation and
smoothness bogus is non bogus
equation.
It's non trivial but seem to be
a very good showcase for this.
Directly applying it to other
scenarios is is challenging so
we haven't unfortunately we
haven't gotten around to finding
a good way to to leverage this
for it.
Reword never Stokes problems or
so but but not to say.
But what about foundation mods
in general?
Like, well, how was your group
tackling this?
What?
What's your strategy in a sense,
you know where, where, where do
you see this going?
Recently we switched pretty much
from these differential solvers
to foundation models.
I was quite skeptical for a TI
for for quite a while.
I think it's also there's also
just quite some skepticism
talking to other people in the
field with foundation models.
I think partly it's because of
the name, right?
Foundation model sounds super
general and I'm sure you and and
most people know these fields of
Pdes are extremely diverse.
The thought of having one model
that just is everything
out-of-the-box is yeah, but is
is a bit unbelievable and I
think also still out of quite a
bit out of reach.
Nonetheless, if you just right
foundation was also by now I
think it's actually not so well
defined.
People use it in in all various
forms and where I think it makes
a lot of sense and in a way it's
also the direction we are
typically tech typically
tackling is to see it as a model
that's pre trained on on
something and then applicable to
other tasks, other problems.
So there's just some disparity
between training data and the
actual application we saw.
We want models to generalise.
Also, generalisation is not a
well defined topic, right?
It's in distribution is clear,
but how far out of distribution
you need to go to have proper
generalization.
It's completely open.
But in the past that's been
really tricky.
Anyway, it's a classical
transfer learning problem.
Now, I think with these
foundation model tools borrowing
a lot from large vendors models,
we can actually do this if we
pre train on on one part and
then apply it to something else.
And how else how how different
is is up for very specific to
problems and and application
domains.
But that seems to work.
And that's specifically what
what I'm quite excited about is
that we notice you can actually
pre train on very cheaply
generated data, offer us
training foundation models in in
3D plus time.
The amount of data needed seems
very scary and also somewhat
impractical given given the
current cost of of doing these
training runs.
But we noticed that in a way you
don't really need these huge
amounts of data.
And I think that that really
changes the picture, that
changes how we can approach
foundation model training.
And I think in a way it makes it
much more attractive as as a
starting point.
Could you maybe go into a little
bit more detail when you when
you talk about not needing as as
much data or all the OR high
quality data?
Right.
So you also thought about this
quite a bit, right, as you
recent paper discussing the the
scaling of of of data and and
computer requirements for fluids
is is a good starting point to
think about it.
What we noticed in this tadpole
work, we we called it typically
was basically that if you have a
good solver.
So it is actually also based in
a way on on previous work on on
this eight bench benchmark with
very synthetic data.
So if you and if you take the
right solver, these spectral
solvers, then you can extremely
efficiently compute super good
solutions for right, a class of
basic PD, ES affection fusion,
these ETDRK solvers in a way,
they're really perfect.
So also doing the learning on
this on this level does not
really make sense because the
solvers are so good, the errors
are so low, you can prove that
they are basically as accurate
as it gets for for these basic
solutions.
So we can basically generate
this data extremely quickly and
very broadly if you bury the
parameters and we notice that
right, you can then pre train a
model with this just generating
a lot of different solutions for
for varying parameter ranges for
these different PD ES from
affection diffusion to transport
to some some higher order terms
with chaos promoters, Yushinski
and some some polynomial
chemical reaction like
constraints.
And basically pre training this
was on this very broad class of
very basic synthetic solutions.
Nonetheless, it's actually not
not a very easy task and
benefits or seems to benefit in
in quite a bit of downstream
tasks.
And the nice thing then is
right, these, these solutions to
these synthetic prones are
really not interested in or
interesting in a way you can
compute them almost as quickly
with the solver from from
scratch basically.
So you can train with it, you
can run it through a model to
get a gradient basically, but
then you can throw it away.
So it's basically just running
the solver alongside you
typically have written and all
the four GPU.
So one GPU does the data
generation, the other 3 train
and just generates data on the
fly, throws it away right after
it produces more data.
But the nice thing is it's
produced on the fly and it's
really just a continuous stream
of data to train with.
You don't, you don't have
limitations on the bandwidth
side on the hardware disk space
to manage 10s of terabytes of or
hundreds of terabytes to upload
to HPC centres for for anyone
who's tried this, it's, it's
very painful actually to do this
and it's not trivial.
So right, having this online
data generation with the
training is is really quite neat
and worked quite well in our
experiments.
But where?
Do you, how do you see that
progressing?
I mean, I think this has often
been my challenges and you've
been on both sides of it.
You know, one side of it is,
let's take realistic in well, in
if we assume that the model
should work for industrial scale
problems, then you know, the the
idea is you generate data like
you did with the Super wing or,
or now this highlight aero ML or
any or company, you know,
generating data.
And then you you train on that.
And you know that is one
argument.
And the other one is you're
starting from the far left side
of basic PD ES.
But where do you see how can
they go in the middle?
The basic PDS are just can you
go to Navier Stokes?
How does that scale to more
complexity?
Yeah.
So what we basically notice is
that even if we pre trained also
one of the one of the tricks
basically that I didn't mention
just now was also that we don't
train for a time evolution.
It's really more of a of a
latent space representation that
is learned for for single
spatial fields.
So there's no time in the pre
training and then the the basic
architecture is basically so so
general that you can just put
time on top of that, right.
So we learn in this latent
space, one step to the next
seems to work nicely.
And also time in a way is also
specific application already I
would argue, right.
There are steady state problems
that that essentially go for an
equilibrium already or an
average solution where time does
not really the the evolution of
time doesn't really play a role.
It's more a mapping of some
initial conditions in the
geometry or so to the steady
state.
You might need time and other
solutions, the occasions where
you really want to resolve what
happens over time.
But in a way taking that out of
pre training already makes sense
in in retrospect I think.
And then with the synthetic PD
ES, probably you also might not
get the out-of-the-box best
accuracy for right high accuracy
aerodynamic predictions.
But I think it, it seems to be a
very good starting point also
for Navia Stokes.
So what I see as a practical
kind of approach in in the
future would be to pre train
some very generic models as a
starting point.
And then step by step was first
further pre training stages move
towards more application
specific models, aerodynamics,
maybe other one, maybe aero
acoustics, other one, maybe
structural structural problems
or branch off different
directions.
But pre training doesn't need to
be restricted to these canonical
PD ES, but could go in certain
stages and then at a company you
might for a certain use case
then have 10 final models to
fine tune the the last one for a
certain application.
I just think just this this
outlook is basically not
starting from scratch but pre
training and then downstream
needing less data.
I think it's potentially a good.
So do you so because of that, do
you feel that there can be, I
mean how general can these
models go do you think?
I mean if you if you put a
looking glass.
Admittedly, that's an open
question and in in a way also we
were surprised that the bonus
can learn something useful from
these admittedly relatively
useless synthetic solutions.
But it's a really interesting
question to analyse what they
actually learned.
So there are we had we had some
hypothesis.
Basically, do they really just
learn or less random abstract
fields or physical structures
like the key modes?
Or do they learn differential
operators like Also, these PD ES
are built from certain
derivatives and it's difficult
to disentangle.
But for example, the initial
conditions are relatively easy
to test.
So the PD ES are initialized.
If you only train with these
random fields, the models
actually also learn something,
but it clearly does less good on
the Stokes than if you pre train
with the PD ES.
So basically a transformation of
initial conditions into actual
states of a of APDE seems to be
beneficial.
I think this is just the first
step.
It's it's actually not right
right now difficult to
disentangle what they learned.
And intuitively, I think the
network network currently don't
has any reason to clearly
disentangled modes or
differential operators or so
probably just mixes the most
prominent structures that that
come up.
But in a way also most of the
problems we're dealing with in
in engineering and in real world
applications are typically built
from certain like building
blocks to differential equations
in a way have a have a very
limited vocabulary.
So my guess is that the
structures that come from these
actually in a way can be pre
trended and reused.
Yeah.
And I guess the the other, I
mean, so maybe to put it in a
nutshell, in terms of your
research and your thinking, do
you think it is more better to
go down this sort of PDE route
with an integrated solver in the
loop rather than coming from the
other direction, which is just
generating lots and lots of, you
know, if if we're trying to
ultimately get to predict a
wing, practically speaking, do
you think it's better just to
simulate a million wings in all
different conditions or to sort
of build up from the ground from
a sort of PDE based that may be
pre trained?
And then you go to more complex,
more complex, because they still
do feel like different
directions to go, right?
The PD ES definitely aim for
generality in a way I think also
based on previous work, if your
data set is large enough, if you
have enough data to really train
the large scale model
specifically for the task you're
interested in, I don't think you
actually need this this much
more generic starting points.
So if you can do this, I think
probably it's not not necessary.
It's really more motivated by
the practical constraints.
I think at the moment that's
especially in in 3D for large
scale Pdes, it's actually
difficult to gather these really
large collective, Yeah.
I, I'm, I'm, I'm kind of
intrigued on that point just
because, you know, as that fluid
intelligence paper tried to
point out, there is a certain
economic challenge, which is
feels to be different than
ChatGPT where, you know, chat
GBTS cost does not really
include the, the data, the token
cost per SE.
And, and therefore it's all on
the trading side.
And I, I still, I still
fundamentally wonder, is it
massively inefficient?
Because someone said to me,
well, if you run cases, maybe
I'll pose this question to you.
So someone said, OK, so if you
need to generate 2,000,000 cases
in order to fully scope out what
is a reasonable definition of
problems within fluids, So all
possible planes and cars and
data centers and all the rest of
it, and then you use all that to
train a model.
Haven't you already got the
solution from CFD for most of
these problems anyway?
Because you probably run it
like, what?
Where is it just a, you know,
you're almost so massively in
distribution that you almost
could just map that solution to
a new.
Yeah.
But you're right that that that
might happen.
So 2 million seems seems a
little bit scarce for for actual
geometry aside.
But if if you could pretend
enough of them, I guess you
could hope that any new one you
run would actually just hit
close to one of the existing
samples basically.
Then I think a practical problem
would still be that essentially
you need to look up this data
somehow, right?
So these two all right, millions
of simulations would probably be
I don't know how how many
petabytes or gigantic lots of
storage.
So it could be beneficial to pre
train just to have a reduced
compressed representation to be
able to efficiently look up
these data points and maybe also
give give some smoothness in
between, right.
That's even if your exact
geometry is not in there, you
get in in between solutions.
So it, it could actually still
be beneficial from a from a
practical standpoint.
But yeah, given how difficult it
is and, and the amount of data
involved with these online
generated data sets, it seems
that you can actually get away
with much less data in a way.
The the hope would be that you
do this as a first step and then
right maybe you can get away
with 1,000,000 off for CFD
simulations or significantly
less at least to to get to the
same level of accuracy.
Practically in your maybe one of
the topics that also interests
people and be interested to see
how from a coding point of view
you've seen this progress.
So you raise the point of
training the data, sorry,
generating the data, throwing it
away because you're ultimately
using it.
So maybe you could talk a little
bit more what you saw at the
challenges from an
implementation from a coding
point of view, because that
that's I guess also part of the
problem if everybody's
generating these hundreds of
thousands of cases offline and
then trying to bring into a
model that also seems quite
inefficient, so.
The infrastructure work is quite
substantial and I think it's
getting better also largely
thanks to all the methodology is
converging on this LLM
transformer style processing,
which probably is is one of the
reasons why now finally we're
we're in a stage where it starts
to work because also we have the
the tools and and outlooks how
to stay up things up to these
larger resolutions.
It's nonetheless still quite
tricky in practice.
So also in my group took quite a
while to to figure out how to
put these pieces together.
And there are numerous caveats
and, and things that can go
wrong.
So actually, admittedly, one of
the things we're still fighting
with is the non linear scaling.
So even with Transformers, which
which are demonstrated to scale
up to billions of parameters, if
you take one model and you just
try to increase the size of of
layers and the overall capacity,
it's highly non linear.
So it's not guaranteed to to
work if you rerun this, just
longer with an increased size.
Most likely at least need to
adjust the learning rate, the
additional hyper parameters like
smoothing of of network states
over time.
How to actually adjust how to
scale up the size of the network
in terms of this bedding space
that the Transformers have or
the the weights for the
additional components that
unfortunately or it seems it's
necessary to revisit for, for
every new case again and also
for the for the PD case,
unfortunately.
So it's still not not right, not
not really trivial to.
Do this.
And then right, also just
ability, we fought quite a bit
just with with the data
management.
So we rely on these official
compute infrastructures here
from the very end.
And in Germany we now have
supercomputers with a fair
number of GPUs.
But your someone need to get the
data over there and then you can
just store it on on temporary
drives.
And if you don't pay attention
then suddenly your trainer data
has gone if you don't train
often enough and issues issues
like this basically.
But how did you solve that with
some of the just wanted to
double click on the you know one
GPU to generate the data, 3 to
trade.
How?
How were you getting around the
passing the data between?
Yeah, I'm just trying to learn a
little bit more how you approach
that that topic of the online
training.
With the with the online
training, so right, the classic
approach would be right there.
You, you have your huge data
sets on disk and eventually if
you don't want to overfit to
what fits into memory, you
somehow need to get it from the
disk, get it to the to the GPU's
with this large data set that
that becomes a bottleneck, at
least for right, actually for
even if you've hundreds of
millions of parameters on HPC
systems, I think we notice
especially and the the hardware,
the interconnects are good, but
not fast enough to really get
the data in quickly enough for
training.
So the standard set up would be
right.
You have your DP us they, they
need to load the data from this,
then shuffle it through the
network to get a gradient and
they need to load the next
sample basically.
And for this online training, we
are already basically forced to
deal with a separate process
that does the generation.
So it's natural to put a buffer
in between.
So you basically have a, a
buffer that is filled up by the
simulator and then the training
sets just pull the data from
there or you take a random
sample that's available, then
train with it.
And we try to replace it as
quickly as possible.
So in practice this this doesn't
guarantee every sample is used
only once, but you can measure
right the the throughput of your
simulator versus the training
and it's typically at least
below 2, so somewhere between
11.5.
The South descendants get reused
before they get replaced.
So did you buffering?
That's interesting.
I mean, I need to look a little
bit more at the the paper and
the code, but that was, that was
the bit that I guess I was
assuming maybe for your PDE
problem is easier.
But if we're doing what is,
let's say if we want to have
something really accurate and
we're doing an LES simulation,
the actual LES simulation might
need to run on 64 GPUs for like
8 hours, but the training is
obviously way faster than that.
So do you have any thoughts on
that?
How you would balance from a
time from a loading point of
view?
So my guess is that that's why
this online training so far
hasn't really taken off before
because like you mentioned for
all classic simulations, exactly
you have the the warm up time
until you get some equilibrium
that's physically valid and that
that could be used and it might
take for for realistic reward
case might take hours until
you're in that regime and need
fair number of of CPUs at least
or DP US if you have a modern
solver.
So that's, that's really
unattractive because the, the
speed of generating the data is
way below what you need for
training, which is why I think
it's actually so interesting to
use these canonical PDS with
these Spectra solvers because
it, it's really, the solver is
basically as fast as, as a
network or typically we run
actually the, the training we
run on little regions like 64 ^3
and the solver typically produce
large, produces larger ones like
256 or so.
And even those are pretty close
to the, to the training speed.
And then you can basically cut
out different pieces for data
augmentation.
But it, it matches quite nicely.
So I think without such a solver
doing a large scale pre training
is is infeasible.
I think there are some
approaches doing this, but you
if you want to match the
generation capacity with the
training capacity you would need
for a supercomputer to generate
data on the fly just to feed a
decent sized model.
Yeah, that though then my other
thought was actually whilst it
takes 8 hours on 64 GPUs, let's
say, to do it, that is the
entire simulation.
But actually to generate one
time step is probably only a
second or two seconds.
So part of my interest, and
maybe some groups already doing
this is training per time step.
Now, the variation from one time
step to another is pretty
minimal.
So you could argue that you're
not really learning that much
between, but you are.
That's the only way I could see
that the time scales being
similar, You know, which I guess
ultimately addresses one of the
challenges that I think many
people have, which is almost all
of the standard data sets and
standard machine learning
approaches do take some time
averaged solution.
You know, which if you're trying
to get to real problems and real
accuracy, turbulence is
transient, you know, and giving
just a steady state answer or
time average answer is, you
know, not, not really
representing the ultimate goal
of like weather forecasting.
I guess you would have the
temporal evolution of it.
So I don't know how you how we
can get over that.
Issue.
I think it's a great order to to
really target time.
I think there are some probably
what I see there are quite some
hurdles for for practitioners
because we have all these
pipelines set up for for
averaged quantities.
All right, potentially I think
this would be would be neat to
have in place.
Regarding your first point
though, with the kind of
exploiting the, the fast solves
over time for data generation.
Unfortunately he was tadpole
with his online training.
We have some, some, some data
that is pointing to to problems
there.
So what we noticed even with
this online generation if we
don't replace the data fast
enough.
So if this reuse is too high of
our our pre trained buffer
basically the models do start to
overfit.
So typically for foundation
models you're dealing with
fairly large models.
So ours are not even extreme,
but on the order of maybe 100
million parameters.
And if the samples are reused
too often, the bars already we
saw some signs of of performance
deteriorating if the generator
didn't catch up.
And basically this was just out
of pure luck because of of
scheduling on these high
performance systems of right.
If there's some one of the GPUs
is is for some reason slower and
suddenly on when training run
you reuse the data more often.
We saw a drop in performance and
even there the the correlation
between the samples was not
overly strong.
So it's still generative fair
amount of data.
But I would be worried if you
have these strongly correlated
samples over time.
Even if you're able to swap them
out and reload reload different
configurations for a solver, I
think this would be would be
difficult to ensure that the
variability in the data is large
enough to right not overfit a
large model.
Yeah, that's a very good point
actually, that that's, that's
the gang.
Yeah.
The drawback that we, the
temporal evolution of the PDE
needs to be small in for
numerical reasons, you know, to,
to avoid blowing up, you know,
for because of the CFL
constraints, etcetera.
So you you're kind of forced to
slowly March in time, whereas I
guess you're right, if you feed
the machine learning model that
it's just going to keep seeing
essentially the same solution,
very similar.
Ones that.
And and yeah, that's, but that's
where I still see a bit of a
fundamental.
I just don't see.
That's why I see almost as
that's why I was interested in
your differentiable physic, your
your code writing essentially
because I feel some of the
breakthroughs in this probably
will come through a clever,
clever use of the training being
linked to the data generation in
a way that.
I think right now our focus is
on foundation was I'm also
confident that at some point
it's going to make sense to
bring the solvers back in the
our our tests back back then a
few years ago basically did did
pretty short.
If you have a solver, there's
anything decent, the learning
task is just simpler.
So once once we have kind of
reached the decent reasonable
capacity for this pre training,
I think it's might make a lot of
sense to put a solver back into
the loop to just make it more
accurate in the end.
Also, they are it's it is
challenging at the moment at the
at the scope given the current
infrastructures and and large
scale models.
It's typically challenging to
just train a single model and in
a decent amount of time and then
trying to get a solver into the
picture and maybe going over
multiple time steps.
Things like this are are tricky,
but it's also going to change
next year's.
Yeah, yeah.
No, I I would agree.
And maybe the the other topic is
around what were some of your
lessons learned from doing, you
know, weather bench and AP bench
and, and some of these more
benchmarking efforts because I
guess that seems to have helped
quite a bit on the weather and
climate side.
So what?
What was some of the genesis
behind those efforts?
So the weather bench effort,
yeah, in retrospect, it's, it's
great that it's, it's doing so
well.
I, I think it's especially, I
guess I should think that so,
right.
What I'm trying to say is
basically the, these benchmarks
have a big impact in the field.
I think by now that is widely
accepted across all the fields.
Back then it was probably more
clear in the vision area where
fair number of of benchmarks
have been around for quite a
while.
But in other fields, like
whether there was very little,
basically having established
benchmarks and libel evaluations
is really important for for any
discipline in the field.
I think that's a nice pointer
and right, it's civic.
It's it's quite some work
collecting the data, right and
thinking about what should be in
there and how to evaluate it.
So the way those efforts are
really important for any
subfield within any data-driven
discipline.
And I think by now it's great
also in this scientific Yeah, I
feel that this is noticed that
by now more and more benchmarks
are coming out.
I think that's.
Really important you you
recently generated to your group
the Super wing data set.
I mean, where do you see this
going?
And it's a little bit of a
philosophical debate around data
because on one hand you could
argue that we the progress in
this field does seem limited by
data to a certain extent.
And, you know, does it mean that
there should be some coordinated
effort to generate data?
And if so, who should be doing
that?
And what should be the license
attached to it, given that there
is clearly also a commercial
benefit to be had?
That's a good question.
I mean coming from from a
university, I think it's great
if it's all public and as open
as possible.
But given the commercial
interest and also by now the the
key outlook that this will be
useful, that would of course be
great to have support from from
commercial partners in this.
I think it's getting better.
Also more, more companies see
the need for AI and then also
the need for or benchmarks and
data sets on that front.
So I think it's improving, but
definitely an issue where things
could be done and could improve
a lot.
And unfortunately there's so
much to quickly wrap this up.
But I think there's so much
proprietary data with IP rights
and so on that are probably on
some servers and companies that
they that cannot be used.
So it probably needs an effort
to generate data that's free and
and usable.
Yeah, that I keep jumping
between that because on one hand
you could say that it is to the
a bit like maybe open science
experiments, you know, with,
with astronomy or, or, or things
where there's a sort of public
good and a lot of it is funded
through taxpayers.
Ultimately, you know, through
sort of science funding and the
data's made available.
Part of it feels that that would
help all companies, you know, to
be doing it.
But at the same time, is it
really the responsibility of
governments and science to do
this?
It it's it's kind of.
Yeah, that's good to argue about
the companies.
So pay for it if they benefit
from it, that's.
Yeah, that's it.
I just look at, I don't know
about you, but I look at all the
supercomputers in Europe, just
as an example, you know, and you
think how much data could be
generated given that these
systems now are quite large
because they're being scaled up
for the task of also, you know,
large language model training,
etcetera.
You know, if you've got a
cluster with 10,000 GPUs, you
think how much data could you
generate, you know, from fluid
simulations to a 10,000 GPUs,
even just, you know, for a few
weeks or, or you know, or a
month, you know, that does feel
like it could be a, a huge way
of doing it.
And if, if it's only a
commercial company that does it,
they probably have no incentive
to release that data.
And it then becomes hard to
progress the field if only one
company has that data where it
feels like with large language
models, the data has actually
had quite an open movement,
right?
There's quite a lot of open data
obviously around this.
And so, yes, you still could say
you can only make models if
you've got lots of compute, but
there was already a movement now
with open source LMS, you know,
going on, whereas I feel now how
can there be a movement of open
source surrogate models if the
data is not there in an open
way, You know, it it it's.
It's a good point.
It would be a pity if that gets
hidden away due to commercial
interests.
So it's almost the.
Progression of science, I guess,
and this is, I don't know if
you've had this and certainly
now my myself being a commercial
company or the last two
companies that you know that I'm
at, there is always this debate
of open source versus
commercial, and I still find
that a tricky one.
I wondered how you've seen it.
You know what, what at what
point does it help everybody to
be open source?
Yeah, OK, right.
I have AI have a good.
Argument for open source from
from my career at least.
We used to work in computer
graphics basically with movie
studios and I remember 1 of was
my postdoc, one of the first
papers at once at Arthur
conference seeker there.
We basically put up with an open
source code and company
DreamWorks at the time actually
picked this up pretty quickly
and directly used it for for one
of the shots.
And I said, oh, can't we get, or
maybe they can put us in the
credit somewhere.
They send us a poster in the end
and also quite a few of my
friends and kind of laugh or
look all all you got for for
this work.
You put up your code, you got a
poster for it.
Why did you sell it or
something?
A couple of years later, these,
all these movies where it was
used were one of the key things
to apply for one of these test
tech Oscars.
There's also application
procedure.
But in the end, we could show,
look, it's been used in all
these movies.
And this this Oscar actually did
help a lot also for applying for
faculty positions and so on.
So this is largely due to to
open source availability.
It just might impact in the
field.
So I've had very good experience
with this and I'm actually very
happy that now that, yeah, I
feel this is so obvious. 15
years ago it was very, it was
actually the exception that
papers came to code and it's
great.
It's changed so much.
Yeah, it, it does seem an
interesting 1 though, because
it's, given the large amount of
money that's required to develop
models and develop training
data, you know, there has to be
some route to that money coming
back.
Which is why for a commercial
company, if they spend $100
million on compute and they, you
know, they have to think, well,
how am I going to make a
business out of this?
And so it's, it's kind of an
interesting one that is the
business that they, that the
value to the company is not the
model, but how you sort of tweak
the model, so to speak.
And therefore, just because
there's a foundation model out
there which is open source, the
real value is that every single
company needs to customize it,
which I think is the value at
the moment for open source LMS
that ultimately companies still
make money out of it because
everybody realizes that it isn't
fully ready in its base form.
And that actually you take it
and you tweak it and you
optimize it and you know, you so
that so there's money still to
be made.
And that's what I kind of wonder
on the fluids surrogate
modelling side or even beyond
that, it would it still be in
the interest of some company to
make it because ultimately the
money will be made customizing
it and therefore being open
helps the whole community to
develop it faster and make it
more competitive against close
models.
Right, that's definitely.
But I hope that, that we can go
towards some foundation models
or some generalizing models in
the field that can then be
fine-tuned and adaptive to
adapted to different, different
applications quite easily.
I think that's, that's been
super useful in the LLM field.
And I, I do see potential there
on the, on the PDE front and
through its front.
So, and I think if, if at some
point it's clear that you can
get a really good result, right,
if if you actually download this
model and then right fine tune
it on your couple of wing data
set cases or so for certain
regime you're interested in,
then.
But there could be a clear
commercial also benefit for a
company and the use case of
supporting these for supporting
these open models.
Yeah.
So that could imagine in an
infrastructure environment
working quite well also in this
area, but that definitely needs
a coordinated and a large scale
effort to build it up right now.
Yeah, that that's seems that
there's lots of separate
efforts, I guess going on, but
but not uncoordinated.
I I mean, maybe moving to some
of the final questions for you
is where well, look, I, I guess
a couple of things before we get
to the future looking one.
I'm just interested, where's
your side on the like startups
or academia industry?
Because I've noticed there's a
lot of, in recent years, there's
even more interest in startups
and, and, and the value of
startups.
But then that also in some ways
can conflict with the open
source academic, you know,
mindset.
Where, where have you seen that
in the world?
Have you been tempted with
startups of, of industry?
Where do you see that role of
academia, start-ups and and
industry?
Yeah, it's a good question.
Exactly.
Especially in last one or two
years we've seen a very nice
rise I think in terms of funding
and and also just founding of
all kinds of spin off companies
that are pivots of quite
existing companies towards this
physically eye direction.
So I think also in a way
confirmation that now it's
really starting to work, right,
It's ready for practical
applications.
I've definitely toyed with the
idea so far or also on my side,
there are no immediate plans for
this.
In a way.
I, I had my experience with
industry I for, for visual
attacks and before I'm quite
happy with the Open University
research side.
So I've, I've always been a big
fan of open source and just
being able to put out things and
for, for research.
I mean, it's also effectively a
market with this openness and
impact, right?
You, if you can generate this
later on, you can say, look,
give me more money for research
to do more of, of this.
So it's not the commercial
market, but also their own
market in terms of research
money.
And but I like the openness of
that.
So for now, I think for me
that's personally just because I
like this openness the the
better direction.
But we also, by now we're
working with all kinds of
companies due to the commercial
interests.
Yeah.
But we were basically trying to
do this on the more Open
University side and then work
with individual companies for
maybe adopting or or adapting
these these techniques.
Yeah, I was going to say because
the decking jury if all top
academics create start-ups, then
there will be no academics left
to do that.
The sort of so that that I'm
sure that has been discussed a
little bit in the broader LM
space.
If the only companies doing the
latest stuff because of the
scale are the big tech
companies, then there is a risk
to open science, I guess because
everyone's tempted to go to a
commercial company that maybe
aren't, as you said,
incentivized to be open.
I guess as academia, you are
incentivized to be open because
the reward structure is based
around it publishing grant
money.
Like if everything's closed, I
guess it may help the university
a little bit because of grant
capture or something, but it's
not really the the core aim, is
it?
It's difficult actually for for
universities.
I think in the past quite a few
labs had their in house solvers
and then basically earned money
and and funding.
With direct we basically support
or consulting contracts with
companies.
But right now I think especially
in the fast moving AI field, it
was, it was closed solutions,
you would see very little impact
at the at the moment, Stephanie.
Works nicely no I, I, I think
that's why I'm always
championing the academic side
because I think people look at
research coming out of tech
companies or research coming out
of the but forget that actually
most of the things start in the
university most most fundamental
ideas and.
They need to be kept being
promoted and that's where I feel
the data's the issue, because
the they if you don't have open
data, then you can't actually
universities can't progress and
can't publish and can't advance.
The state-of-the-art.
If everything's done closed
door, it actually hurts
progress, doesn't it?
Yeah.
So LLMS will be interesting to
some extent, right.
That's there have been
initiatives of training open
LLMS, but some of them I guess
did fairly well.
But the top models are not open.
And right now I think there are
very few people who really can
or try to train their own LLMS.
That's really become a very
tough field, at least to operate
in.
Yes, yes.
So where do you see if you have
your looking glass or your, you
know, crystal ball?
If we were to talk again in five
years time, where where do you
think the conversation will be
going?
What what do you think will be
the breakthrough moments?
Do you feel like we're going to
be just incrementally over the
next five years or do you
perceive some big breakthroughs
or leap?
Just hope that we're going to
see this breakthrough in terms
of adoption.
So now also these all these
initiatives on commercial side I
think point towards the field
really starting to work.
So I hope that five years we we
really see widespread adoption
for for actual applications in a
way sounds a bit boring, right,
just being it used in in
practice.
But I think right also working
on this for almost 10 years.
I think it's about time that we
that we do see that it's got
it's really useful for for real
world world things.
So I just hope that now we are
at a stage where this really can
be can be pulled off, but in the
field is really progressing
extremely quickly.
And so one of the, one of the
outlooks that I've been
intrigued about are these world
models, right?
Like vision by now, they're
already going beyond foundation
models or specific language and,
and just visual models towards
ones that just capture the whole
world.
And right, also vision now
notices actually physics is an
important part.
You only see so much.
A lot of the complexity comes
from things you don't directly
see like air moving or so I
think that's a really
interesting outlook to to really
simulate basically the the whole
world around us on a larger
scale with the physics
accurately.
I think that could also be super
useful for engineering and and
real applications in a bunch of
areas.
But getting that right seems
like a whole different level on
top of what we currently dealing
with just only doing the physics
right with the foundation
models.
But I think it's a really
interesting outlook.
Yeah, it's actually a good point
there.
Yeah, I forgot to ask you about
that.
That I still don't fully get.
I mean, I understand the world
models are obviously one very
big use case is robotics and
driving drop, you know,
autonomous vehicles and sort of
giving that synthetic data to
help them to operate in the
world, The bit that I guess I'm
less sure on.
And I wonder whether
economically and scientifically
is the physics side, you know,
does it make a difference how
good the physics is like, as
long as it looks right?
And this, This is why I'm
interested, because your movie
background, like does it, does
it matter to the robots and to
the autonomous vehicles?
Actually, I do think that at
least for robots, the physics
play a big role because
ultimately the, the action that
you're generating is, is the
control right of your, of the
actuators of the actual things
that the robot should do.
And you need to estimate surface
properties, the weight of an
object, weight distribution
stability and all these things
to at least in a, in a variable
environment to interact with
the, with the world.
So think for robots by now rigid
body type or in some somewhat
deformable and physics are
playing quite a role.
So I would I would guess that it
does make a difference for
autonomous driving.
We could argue at the end you
only need to take right?
Is it a dangerous situation or
would something have gone wrong?
You can probably do a lot
without having to go through the
whole crash or actually
simulating how the car would
tumble or crash into a building
or so.
That might not be so important,
right, As long as you can detect
this would have gone wrong.
But for robots actually having
to really interact with objects,
I can imagine that plays a
larger role.
And then again looking towards
fluids, I, I think the challenge
also in, in the current
development pipelines is this
interaction with the real world.
I mean, I think in the end, the
current validation and
certification still goes through
a lot of testing status and then
you have all kinds of real world
flights and and experience to
make sure that the systems
really do what they should in
the real world.
But if you could shift some of
that into an earlier stage, I
think that that could also be
definitely interesting.
If right, you could have
different environment
conditions, different flow
conditions, and you could have
an have an object interact
dynamically in in such an
environment.
Yeah, I guess maybe maybe you're
right to maybe the examples I've
looked at, you know, if you look
at a robot walking around a
factory floor or it has no the
the drag, the lift, the thermal
properties are very second or
third order effects.
They don't really influence how
it's performing.
But I guess you're right.
If it was like a drone in the
sky or a boat in the water, then
the physics actually do make
quite a bit of a difference in
and then I guess it really is
depending what's the use of
these world moles, if they
really are like a true, true
representation of the world for
that drone or or helicopter or,
you know, I guess the moment the
autonomous vehicle, you're
right, is it's more sensory.
You know, like I see there's a
person walking.
It's not to design the car,
right?
It's not to say I see now that
in this real world, by changing
the shape, the drag is lower
because it's actually I guess
maybe that's where you're
thinking, right, that the world
model could be used as a true
synthetic environment or cars, I
guess if you could.
Simulate a rainy and stormy
situation and then really get
feedback on how the rain would
splash around a car, or how gust
of wind would influence driving
stability in extreme conditions.
Or right, all kinds of of
landing and starting scenarios
for planes.
If you could really get feedback
on how all the forming plane
with straining conditions would
would behave.
I think that's that's still
beyond even regular simulation
capabilities that full structure
interactions was changing
conditions are are really
challenging.
You could get some feedback on
these and then ideally put an
optimization loop around them,
right?
You you would want to actually
optimize your, you know, your
wing profile or the shape of of
a vehicle tour behavior in the
whole longer sequence.
I feel like this is also the big
debate, well not big debate, but
a debate around the classic tool
calling thing.
You know, like isn't LLM good at
adding numbers?
No, so just go and call a
calculator.
That's like ultimately, I guess
if you call Chachi BT to add 2
numbers together, it's just
calling a tool of a calculator,
adding the 2 numbers together.
I kind of wonder it's sometimes
in this world of, you know,
world models or optimizing, you
know, is it, is it really that
it's truly integrated into a
world model?
Or is it more likely that there
is a sort of agent workflow
where it's calling a surrogate
model and maybe that's the where
they're two separate models, if
you know what I mean, rather
than just a world model.
It's it's more than a gentic
way, if you know what I mean.
Or not that that would already
be a big step, right, If if you
had any visual model that could
on demand call some physics sub
models surrogates to to get
feedback on how these different
pieces is recognised.
Should should interact of
original bodies.
Actually these days you would
just call it original body
simulator.
You would probably not need a
surrogate.
Yeah, that's.
That's kind of where I always
debate it and that and that's
the traditional one that you
said if the solvers get so fast,
like the spectral solver you
mentioned or now with, you know,
advancements in GPUs, some
people are saying I can do a
simulation in a minute.
And then you think, well, do I
need a surrogate?
If if I can, if the solver can
run so fast?
Right, I think for World War,
it's an interesting challenge
will be to to quickly switch
from from the proximate fidelity
kind of for for rigid bodies or
the former objects of winds or
different feedbacks needed in
the environment.
Sure, if I know I need perfect
rigid bodies for a certain case
that might be ideal, but but
right I need some feedback on on
wind or how right my plastic cup
should deform or should it break
predictions across the all these
different physical phenomena.
I could imagine that a flexible
surrogate that at least gives a
gives the first prediction of
estimates of of what what might
happen there could be
beneficial.
I think that would be tricky to
do with classical simulators.
Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah, that.
I think this is where it's the
classic what's the, what's the
use case of real time?
And sometimes if you go to an
engineering team and I've had
this where you tell them that a
surrogate model prediction in
one second, sometimes they'll
say, well, we don't need it to
do in one second.
You know, it's actually fine If
it takes 5 minutes or even half
an hour, it's OK.
It's not a bottleneck.
Whereas I guess if it's
integrated in a world model or
something, you need it to be
essentially real time or else
the whole value breaks of some
simulation.
You know, like testing a car
moving.
If you have to sort of pause the
simulator for 30 minutes, then
it's not that.
Feel right?
Yeah, I mean real time is is
extremely challenging.
Then you need I guess to to be a
realistic virtual environment
for a person.
Yes, you need milliseconds.
Yeah, very real.
Yeah.
So maybe a final question to you
looking more if, if there's a
student listening to this or
someone doing HD or early in
their career, given, given all
these changes, what would you
recommend someone was would
study as a PhD topic?
You know what was going to
future proof them in this world.
Maybe I'm biased here, but I
think these are really important
techniques.
I, I do see a lot of potential
for AI based techniques.
So I think it's important to
have an understanding to know
the classic, the classic physics
numerics.
But by now within these
numerical tools, I think AI is,
is a super important component.
So I could, could highly
recommend looking at at least
combinations of classic and AI
based methods.
And my, my guess is also that in
the future or the next couple of
of years, we were not going to
be completely replaced by I
don't think chap DPT is going to
take over fluid simulation too
soon.
So having experts that we
understand what's happening
there, I think it's it's going
to be needed for quite a while.
So I think it's still a good
field to to work on.
Yeah, I guess that that's the
the truth, I guess the, the
short, medium, long term, I
guess I see at least now the
short term, there's even more
need for specialists because
frankly, it's almost become that
simulation is more of a popular
topic now.
The fact that all these startups
are getting funded, the fact
that, you know, there's more
money in this space, there's
more need to find out who's an
expert in crash simulations,
who's an expert in acoustics,
who's an expert to help computer
scientists, you know, to develop
these models.
I guess it's only in the very
long term future that you could
imagine.
Maybe you don't need as many
specialists because so much of
that knowledge is now ingrained
in these models.
But there's a, in the short
term, it's almost even more
specialists to help.
But deep, deep specialists, I
guess you really understand it
that, that at least that's the
way I I'm seeing things at the
moment.
And I think that's usually a
great topic for a PhD, really
getting to the bottom of things.
So I just, it's a nice
opportunity to work on one topic
for a couple of years and yeah,
get as much understanding as
possible.
So on.
Right now I think PhD is in this
area.
Still a very good idea.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, I agree.
Well, thank you so much for
taking the time to speak.
I mean, I, I find all these
topics fascinating and one of
the things I'll do is put a list
of the papers in the, in the
show notes because I think
actually there's a lot more to
gather from looking in the
details and, and looking at the
codes that your, your, your
group did.
So I know we didn't have time to
cover all in, you know, full
detail, but I'll, I'll put a
list and hopefully people can
find the time to read through
the papers.
That's a good idea.
Oh, great discussion.
Thanks for the invite.
Yeah, interesting.
We'll speak again in two years
time and we'll see if the
predictions are.
That's interesting.
Thank you.
Thanks.